it's a surprisingly dangerous mission
safely navigate the skies of one of the
most iconic tourist destinations in
America the helicopter pilots of Niagara
Falls battle extreme wind and
unpredictable weather conditions all to
give tourists that one spectacular view
sometimes it is very scary you try not
to let the fear overcome you so you
control the aircraft you get it back to
a safe environment so you go home at
night that's the name of the game go
home
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Stanley Smith Kowski I've
been flying over Niagara Falls about 20
years and each day is different I spent
20 years in military I've flown in
Germany England Vietnam and the weather
here is that nothing like anything else
[Music]
[Music]
Niagara Falls is beautiful look like
anything beautiful there's a UH glee
side to it the weather here can change
quite rapidly you can have snow showers
and five minutes later you can have
bright sunny blue skies you have to have
a healthy respect for it because it can
go wrong in a matter of minute the winds
can rest up the 30 to 40 miles an hour
when the wind comes around the building
it tends to create mechanical turbulence
either an updraft or downdraft or
swirling and then sometimes when you
make the turn into the wind it's almost
sometimes like hitting a brick wall I've
had instances where the aircraft wanted
to come apart quit flying and we nurse
it down the Drowned we got down and
walked away and it could have ended up
differently without the training without
the knowledge I sometimes think that
Mother Nature is not my friend today
because of the winds or because of the
rain or snow you deal with that
hopefully come out on the good end or
the other thing is you sit they say okay
you win today I'm not going to fly I
[Music]
look at the Falls and I see the beauty
of nature some days after a major storm
comes through the air is so clear you
have maybe 100 miles visibility and it's
just awe-inspiring to be able to see all
that and see the falls from a different
angle I just love it
[Music]